all that [ __ ] i've been through
how'd i come here get this money shot
the [ __ ] i'm doing and then i just get
eight hundred thousand dollars and [ __ ]
i'm saying hey this is right
the key is that
[ __ ] right now
do you feel like you're not worthy of
all this praise and stuff no yes i know
that um
yes this prayers is just i mean it's
nobody god made me interesting no gifted
bro you gifted that's what it is like
not even though like [ __ ] like also you
just you was gifted as a child you met
the right people you you changed your
life you could have just been somebody
yeah but i don't take myself that
serious like no
i'm not taking you serious i'm telling
you like what happened i'm not like
sugarcoating it hey man you you [ __ ]
prayed on the lucky start no no [ __ ]
you did that [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] you had a nintendo game glass
joe [ __ ] yeah but listen right glass
joe [ __ ] you never dig right can you
imagine hearing that all day
yeah yeah no i get like that too you
know that all day
you the man you're the man
i mean yeah no i i feel him on that i
was with jack harlow right yeah we came
to the studio jack was like uh
he was like man you know go to the my
reflexes i wasn't even trying to be i
was like yeah yeah yeah right whatever i
couldn't even embrace the the love he
was giving me because i'm so jaded by
certain things in my industry so i i
know what you're saying it's like gotta
humble you yeah no for sure for sure
even your praises you'll be like yeah i
i i humble you i don't [ __ ] around
almost
numb to the praise
i know yeah yeah all the glory goes to
him all the glory glory
can you talk about one of the humble
combo experiences mike yes being nobody
yeah
can you imagine that like feeling
everybody and not being no was that
though huh what was that in my mind oh
yeah that's the yeah you know what i
mean that's the man in your mind
everything that goes on out here is
right in here if you feel like you
sometimes you feel like you're nobody or
this is before well i know i'm nobody
but i guess um
i know like that we have the expiration
date i'll be dead and it's just i'm gone
i wouldn't be able to confidently ride
home without like i got to refute that
bruh no you don't you're not you're not
like what do you mean nobody bro talk to
me you might tyson bro yeah no but i
think what i'm around mike a lot bro he
he literally i can see where he's coming
from you know what i mean like he
because he's a nikon dude he gets it a
lot more than any of us you know what
i'm saying yeah like it's always people
that's why every time i'm with mike i'm
always like talking about fighting you
know what i mean i don't know your
thoughts on holyfield versus v2 or you
know you are
evolving to what way more than that you
and you a hood [ __ ] you're a street
[ __ ] that knows how to talk to a [ __ ]
to like like about nietzsche like to
know how to talk philosophy with [ __ ]
like you gonna be you're gonna be one of
the big people that yeah you know bridge
the gap you can bridge the gap i can do
that too but also i could suffer about
when i hurt somebody before if i beat
somebody out of this mind and have to
just didn't treat somebody with respect
right so i got that horn in me too that
that oversees all that greatness [ __ ]
right my my guiltless in my mind
everybody got shame bro everybody got
some things everybody no matter what no
matter what your field is everybody got
some things like they their decisions
they didn't you know they wish they
didn't make you know what i'm saying i
don't know yours and then this that's
that's probably something for some
another time but i'm just saying
everybody nobody perfect bruh nobody's
perfect but something i just think that
you live with a lot of like a guilt like
a lot of guilt and it's unnecessary and
you have to be able to accept the
flowers you have to because bro we're
losing we're losing legends we ain't
losing you no time soon i respect my
inventory more than anything so when i
go back and that's right my inventory
how was i today that i should treat
everybody with respect and advice and if
i pass that i'm good today yeah my start
thinking about [ __ ] i call that [ __ ] a
[ __ ] so i said [ __ ] that [ __ ] not even
saying it but in my mind thinking it and
i didn't pass today bro i've done so
much [ __ ] too bro i call a complex
magazine bro
i they didn't put my one of my albums in
like 2012 in the top like
20 or top 50. and my out this [ __ ] went
like it should the numbers were great
and the reception was great my name put
it i called them i called the building
threatened everybody there really was
going
coming up there on that time until
[ __ ] like was like yo bro what are you
doing this is a magazine you know what
i'm saying
like bro like sometimes like sometimes
we can really just
forget all we did and and you said you
call this [ __ ] that call that [ __ ]
that call that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you evolve [ __ ] you you will
never level of a person right now but
you gotta do that inventory you can't
say [ __ ] that without doing the
invitation
i don't even remember i don't even
remember what we
listen your conscience don't lie to you
you know what you did even when you
didn't do it
you know something was not right to say
yeah
yeah you're right mike it's like i
learned i learned so much for you mike
and it all goes back to the basics of
thought the basics of inner peace the
basic of love you know what i'm saying
like it's so much it's so much it's so
simple if you really deep down look at
it but we all have sometimes i'm a self
how can i not be selfish [ __ ] i
always hear that but as long as don't
you accept it mike don't you don't you
recognize and accept when you are
selfish you're not selfish all the time
listen um i don't try to accept it i try
to evacuate it no get it away from me
buying a car buying the house for me
don't do it no more it doesn't move me
no more yeah you know everybody's been
doing buying something
you're doing doing that good you know
now in a different perspective now your
motors are different now mike yeah
he's talking about evolve when did you
feel like the faces that you've evolved
in your career
or
in your thought process
the toe the toe did everything as soon
as i did the toes they're about to have
toes on stockx now toe was just telling
me conquer the world crush the world
like i think i'm like like 16. don't
know that [ __ ] was telling me this [ __ ]
and listen it's telling me this [ __ ] i
got this [ __ ] show
i got this [ __ ] big marijuana company
and listen right that's the toad
i'm not smart enough to navigate this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you talking about nietzsche
and usually
i don't know me i don't know
you smart don't like the
self-deprecating thing i get it though i
get it though because you've been
touched
let's run it back dude
there is a ring here but we're going to
cut it back close it close it off for us
bro what message you guys why the [ __ ]
is mike tyson punch out so
[Music]
hard you